[Musique]
bon je pense que vous avez compris
aujourd'hui je vais pas vous faire des
démo
aujourd'hui pas de roue pas de grand
écart
je vais juste vous parler peut-être de
temps en temps je vais boiter c'est tout
pour vous expliquer rapidement je me
suis amputé pendant une compétition mais
tout va bien je me suis déjà rompu
celui-ci quand j'avais 15 ans donc je
sais exactement ce qui se passe et je
sais que la saison prochaine je serai en
mesure de refaire des compétitions donc
tout va bien ne vous inquiétez pas pour
moi voilà enfin bon avant d'entrer dans
le vif du sujet j'aimerais que vous vous
posiez deux petites questions
est-ce que vous êtes déjà senti
différents des personnes de votre
entourage
et
est-ce que vous avez déjà été victime du
regard des autres
pour ma part je me suis toujours senti
très différent des personnes de mon
entourage et le regard ou plutôt le
jugement des autres a toujours été une
source
d'incompréhension pour moi
par exemple lorsque j'étais en
maternelle je savais pertinemment que
j'étais attiré par les hommes parce que
j'avais deux petits copains donc j'étais
fou amoureux
en revanche contrairement aux autres
petits garçons qui avaient des petites
copines
j'en parlais pas trop je m'inventais pas
parce que je savais qu'il y avait un
tabou autour de l'homosexualité
mais je savais pas pourquoi
à cet âge je savais pas ce que le mot
homosexuel voulait dire mais j'avais
déjà entendu de nombreuses fois le mot
[ __ ] où baltringue et je savais que
c'était quelque chose de négatif
donc je savais que pour mon
environnement et pour mon entourage ce
que j'étais était quelque chose de
négatif quelque chose de honteux
et surtout quelque chose dont il faut
pas parler
pour faire plaisir aux autres et surtout
pour m'éviter les ennuis
je parlais pas de cet aspect de moi
pour faire plaisir aux autres et surtout
pour éviter que ma famille et que les
personnes à l'école me harcèle
je faisais comme si tout allait bien
mais c'est faux
j'étais comme
[Musique]
hanté par le regard des autres
au bout d'un certain temps je me suis
mis à réfléchir et je me suis posé la
question finalement le regard des autres
qu'est-ce que c'est
de manière très simple
le regard des autres c'est la vision ou
plutôt l'idée que les gens se font nous
par rapport à ce qu'ils ont entendu au
vu de nous
ce qui veut dire que c'est ni une
science exacte il a vérité absolue
c'est une opinion
qui appartient à la personne qui nous
regarde ce qui veut dire que ça nous
concerne pas vraiment et qu'il est pas
nécessaire de trop s'y attacher j'ai
fait ce constat là à l'âge de 10 ans
lorsque j'ai commencé la gymnastique
j'ai découvert la gymnastique rythmique
sur Youtube manière totalement anodine
et je suis tout de suite tombé amoureux
de l'univers un petit peu féerique avait
autour de cette discipline les
justaucorps les strass les couleurs la
musique les mouvements quasi impossibles
à réaliser
toutes ces choses-là ont fait que je
pensais que ce sport là allait être le
lieu où je pourrais m'exprimer sans
avoir à me cacher et le lieu où je
pourrais être moi-même
sans avoir à me censurer
évidemment comme j'avais 10 ans j'ai
tout de suite pensé que je pourrais
devenir champion olympique champion du
monde champion de France et c'était mon
objectif pour moi personnellement péché
d'atteindre cet objectif là
ce que je savais pas à cette époque
c'est que la gymnastique rythmique avec
la notation artistique ce sont les deux
derniers sports olympiques à être
exclusivement ouvert aux femmes ce qui
veut dire que les hommes qui font de la
gymnastique rythmique n'ont pas le droit
d'aller au championnats du monde aux
Jeux Olympiques au championnats d'Europe
au championnat de France Élie ils ne
peuvent pas être reconnus comme sportif
de haut niveau en France et ne peuvent
simplement pas concourir dans des
catégories masculines au niveau national
en plus de ça lorsque j'ai commencé la
gymnastique rythmique j'étais le seul
garçon de mon club
j'étais aussi l'un des seuls garçons à
faire de la compétition au niveau
national en plus de ça j'ai dû faire
face à un problème de taille mon corps
la gymnastique rythmique et un sport
dans lequel on attend de voir une femme
déjà
longiligne et lancer et moi je suis
petit trapu j'ai commencé la gère avec
des pieds plats des genoux cagneux et
encore un peu trop voluptueux pour cette
discipline
c'est quelque chose qu'on m'a très
souvent répété
et c'est quelque chose qui a été dans
mon parcours
récurrent le fait que je sois différent
et que l'on me le rappelle
en revanche ce qui avait de différent
entre moi à 10 ans et moi à 5 ans c'est
que lorsque j'ai commencé la gymnastique
je savais exactement ce que je voulais
pour atteindre ces objectifs je me suis
rendu compte que
j'allais devoir
me détacher du regard des autres
parce que je n'aurai aucun contrôle sur
ce que les personnes pourraient penser
de moi
en revanche ce sur quoi j'aurais le
contrôle ce serait mon comportement et
mes réponses face au jugement
je me souviens exactement du jour où
j'ai eu comme ce déclic c'était au
collège
le dernier cours venait se terminer
j'étais dans les couloirs pour entrer
chez moi pour récupérer mon sac pour
aller à la gym et donc dans les couloirs
un garçon interpelle
m'insulte me pousse et mon sac tombe
sur le moment en récupérant mon sac je
me suis posé la question
est-ce que je le frappe en retour
ou pas
pendant cette très longue réflexion
d'une demi-seconde je me suis rendu
compte que si je m'attirais des ennuis à
l'école ma mère me punirait en
m'interdisant d'aller à la gym et il
faut savoir que ce vendredi là
c'était le dernier jour avant ma
première compétition
donc finalement j'ai pris mon sac j'ai
ignoré la provocation je suis rentré
chez moi j'ai pris mes affaires je suis
parti à l'entraînement et le lendemain
premier objectif atteint première
compétition réussie première place
c'est ce jour là que je me suis rendu
compte que le regard des autres était
pas si important et que il pouvait même
parfois être une distraction
comme beaucoup d'athlètes je me suis mis
à écouter de la musique
pour éviter de me laisser distraire
encore aujourd'hui je sors pas de chez
moi tout seul sans avoir des écouteurs
dans les oreilles c'est devenu comme une
habitude et un moyen pour moi de
relativiser sur le monde et de rester
concentré sur ce que je veux obtenir
aujourd'hui j'ai remporté un certain
nombre de médailles
ma vie professionnelle tourne autour de
ma discipline et de ma différence et
plus personne se moque de moi sauf mon
frère mais ça c'est une autre histoire
pour un autre jour
alors vous
quelle différence avez-vous à promouvoir
quelle différence avez-vous à défendre
mon histoire peut paraître unique
mais quand on y réfléchit bien être
différent c'est quelque chose d'assez
universel
être différent
c'est ce qui nous rapproche des autres
c'est ce qui nous rend humain
alors comme nous avons qu'une vie je
vous incite à la vivre pour vous
et pas pour les autres
[Applaudissements]